بعد اكثر من عام على فوز مرشحها باول
انتخابات رئاسيه ديمقراطيه في مصر حضرت
القاهره جماعه الاخوان المسلمين من ممارسه
انشطتها وجمدت اموالها الحمله ضد الاخوان
تكثفت بعد الاطاحه بالرئيس محمد مرسي في
يوليو تموز الماضي ا ما هي اخر التطورات
فيما يتعلق بالاخوان المسلمين على ارض
الواقع
حاليا
الاخوان المسلمون سيستان فون هذا الحكم
وخلال هذا الاستئناف سيتمكنون من ممارسه
نشاطاتهم بشكل طبيعي حتى صدور حكم اخر وقد
خرجت الجماعه بقوه ضد هذا الحكم ل شجبه
وصفه اياه بغير القانوني مضيفه انها
مؤامره سياسيه ودوافعها موجهه ضد الاخوان
المسلمين وقالت ان هذا لن انصارها من
الخروج الى الشوارع رغم ان القرار يحل
المنظمه وقد يتم مصادره جميع ممتلكاتها
كذلك وهذه ضربه كبيره اخرى
للاخوان